hey everybody my name is Walter Bernays
yet
I'm Brian Porter and we're the hosts of
channel Austin's new show awesome comics
debuting on Channel awesome come March
28th that's right
hey we're here at c2e2 this is day two
of this Saturday the main day so many
people here are you excited I'm excited
yes yes yes yes yes hey everybody its
Bryan here for awesome comics and I got
a couple of really special guests for us
today it's guy I got Scott Snyder and
Greg Capullo artist and writer of Batman
in DC what was the hardest thing about
Batman to write and draw for you
throughout the entire series well I
think for me the hardest thing was the
intimidation factor I mean Batman
he has 75 years of amazing stories
creators that I've looked up to for my
whole life like I've worked on this
character and done stories that are far
better than I could do so when you get
the job you know I remember being like
to my wife maybe I should just like call
in sick for the whole year forever you
know and and what the hardest thing is
owning it where you realize like
everybody that you loved that did Batman
made their own version of Batman their
own version of Bruce that corresponded
to their their passions their worries
their time like they're at their moment
and for me it was about understanding
that I had to do that too and having a
partner like him he was so supportive
made that really possible I feel like
from go and I'm very proud of kind of
how our Batman is very much ours like
it's different than grants or Denny
O'Neal's or everything and I love those
so much but I read ours and I see his
and I'm like that's our Batman you know
you know with anything you know you've
got to try and separate yourself from
the rest of the pack even if it's in a
subtle small way and so many Batman
artists and they've all been great but
and even though I inherited Jim Lee's
designs when I took over 52 you know I
still tried to modify it to make it a
bit more my way you know I've always
tried to make my boot Bruce more more
heavy limbs and
let's rip to the bone kind of like a lot
of guys do that spray-painted on suit
you know I always hate that every hero
looks like that Batman I think looks
more dangerous heavier you know just a
little more heavier I'm pre contest
bodybuilder Batman you know and and a
lot less features on the mask none of
that furrow brow and stuff I try and
keep that to the barest minimum because
you don't mean it's like the less
features to me is again more
intimidating so how do you guys feel
exiting Batman and like what do you
think about just like going on a new new
avenues new projects and stuff like that
how do you feel about it I feel like the
same way he does about you know getting
off the title in some ways after we've
done a lot that we could do and the book
is still doing really well and and
hopefully it makes people more excited
when we come back together after he does
his projects and I work on this stuff
for me it's not really sad because it
feels like oh we're just gonna go to the
next thing soon and work on something
else soon and you know so yeah with me
you know I think we're stepping off at a
good time you know we're still bringing
the heat and you know certainly I wasn't
feeling like I was burnt out on the
character or anything like that but you
don't want to get to that point where
you're starting to feel you know my legs
are starting to go you know but you know
because we've all seen it in like
television shows and everything else
where you know they're right and I and
they and they just keep running it until
it just sinks we could always at some
point revisit Batman
so we recharged we're away from it we
take a little breath of air and if we go
back we come back strong we never got to
the point where fans are going Jesus
Christ can't wait for that team to get
the hell off the book and I'm so
here with Batman and Huntress what's
going on guys another day in paradise
just lay in some Harley Quinn's Harley
Quinn's all right by the the get up I'll
guess your favorite band in movies day 9
but tell me is it it's hard to decide
now obviously the Dark Knight Returns
part 1 & 2 is it's yes it's getting
there you can't beat that novel what's
yours I beg to differ Adam West with the
time bomb all the way I got you
are you guys looking forward to Batman
vs Superman absolutely no no there's a
lot of mixed opinions on it why is it so
mixed I don't know maybe because of Ben
Affleck but he looks boss bachelor it's
not like it's just I feel like they're
gonna throw too much in it like
spider-man 3 it's gonna be two and a
half hour movie
aren't you Jim Jade Roz Jim J Roz Jim J
Roz yeah Jim hey it's Brian here with
Darth Maul we got a little bit of info
coming about the dark side of the force
I have no idea what he's talking about
okay you don't sound as menacing as I
thought you're going to would you like
me to cut you in half
no sir so I see that the dark side of
the fourths force doesn't have a dental
plan
any thoughts on that drive something
with my tooth
you know this has been pretty cool so
far you know a little two-man group here
but I feel like we're missing something
poor do you know what I mean yeah maybe
uh maybe had a girl girl we're gonna
find one of those though it's Brad uh
c2e2 hey hey what's your name
hi I'm Ayanna Ayanna uh are you
interested in co-hosting a comic book
talk show with me and my friend Porter
here sure why not look credit take this
hey guys right the Supergirl panel right
now and as you can see it's super PAC so
we're gonna go ahead and head on over
and check it out
do me a favor and press that button
right there hey guys I'm here with my
friend Joe and he's dressed as cubone
and I love it did you make this costume
yourself I did actually
awesome how long did it take why'd you
have that work out it took about a week
actually what did you make it out of it
looks pretty sturdy the inside is
styrofoam and on the outside it's a coat
of bondo which I had to like carve and
sculpt and paint and and the bone and
everything yep yep yep that's so cool
awesome what's been your favorite part
of the con so far
well everyone else's costumes just going
around seeing however how much work
everyone puts into it's really fun
awesome well thanks so much we'll catch
you around the car
I can't dance at all so these two ire
rhythm sections I'm do you want me hey
guys we're just finishing up day to
Saturday here at c2e2 and it was a lot
of fun was a really long day so come
join us again tomorrow on Sunday for the
third and final installation of CTV -
are you gonna be there tomorrow or are
you leaving me by myself how's that work
no I'm gonna be there oh cool are you
gonna be there well I'm gonna be there
so we'll see you tomorrow no cuz we all
love a whole lot of money even if you
don't worship money a whole lot of money
it's a very good thing so hoping for a
whole lot of money